you can see
everybody that's speaking better do you
want to speak of you so that when
somebody's speaking before the entire
screen
hi i can confirm that it's now live over
the internet thank you well good
afternoon everyone so we're just letting
you know before we start
the room with myself for the cabinet
meeting is karen hanson
and marie shaw because we're socially
distanced
item one that apologies
decorations of interest members are
requested to declare the existence
which are any disposable peculiar
interests and no other interests
not already on their registered
interests in any item on the agenda
and withdrawal from the meeting at the
appropriate time
council cupid uh just
it's on my register but rick the written
item i think it's item seven
the same for me thank you
thank you so item three minutes of the
last meeting so to approve as a correct
record the
minutes from the cabinet meeting held on
the 12th of march
2020 those minutes have been circulated
so do we have a proposal that
they are accurate please thank you
council parking secondary council powell
thank you all in favor
thank you is carried so they'll be
signing due course
so item for older people strategy for
2020
2023 so over to you please counsel dale
sorry i'm back i'm sorry i was still on
you
you all heard me say me now yes yeah
yeah okay sorry i'm trying to be
technologically advanced and use mom.gov
at the same time as the um as using the
same ipad for go to meeting so i'll
probably just there's a bit of a delay
here
i'll just get the paper up
yeah so this is uh well members will
recall
um at the previous informal cabinet
meeting probably a month or two probably
a couple months ago now
uh that we uh we received a report on
the
on the older people's housing strategy
it's now been through a process with i
think the agreement was following the
meeting there will be more consultation
and that has now happened the leader and
myself have reviewed the final document
and have approved it to come here today
as we know it's it's um it's a council
plan commitment that we would
um develop a person's person's
strategy and it sets out the the vision
and our strategic
priorities for supporting all the people
within the district over the next three
years
uh with our commitment to improving
their lives and the opportunities
available to them
i think the document is a very very good
one it's very concise
it's full of very useful figures um it
contains a key strategy and it's all
linked to the key strategy which is
a district where older people can live
work and visit with the confidence
that they can access the opportunities
activities and high quality services
required to independently maintain a
good quality of life
and then the structure of the document
is largely around
three key kind of values which is have
informed older people
where they're able to harness
opportunities available to them where
they're informed and they understand
and have access to information about
those opportunities
for independent older people where
they're able to maintain living
standards
uh and suitable uh for their needs
and also included older people so where
they have access to
services and community networks and and
obviously
to make sure that our services are as
inclusive as possible
for older people to access them it
includes a range of commitments within
each of those three
main main kind of aims which
i won't go through in any detail i'll
assume you've all read them
um i don't think there's anything
further to say other than this is a
welcome step
forward it's obviously as i say part of
our council plan commitments to deliver
this
it's a very well written report it
includes lots of information
and hopefully we can get it out on our
communications channels to to show that
we
um that we really are listening and we
we we have strategies to try and
uh try and improve the lives of all the
people within our district
of which there are many because we know
that there is a particularly um
aging population within northeastern so
i'm happy to move
across recommendations the only
further caveat i have around the paper
is i would like it
really to be a living document and
perhaps it would
be useful to add a recommendation for us
to
review uh progress on those commitments
maybe in a year's time
and perhaps update the plan and the
strategy required
thank you are there any comments or
questions
council powell i'd just like to say that
i think it's a vast improvement on the
original document
and i'm happy to second it
thank you and uh councillor kenyon uh
just said also
um i agree with what alex's last comment
was about the additional recommendation
about
doing the review and having it as a
living document
thank you and uh steve
yes sir thank you leader yes i think
council dale's point about have been a
living document is key there's a lot of
work happening
within the sector at the moment because
of addressing social isolation
because of the current situation that
we're in and a lot of work has been um
an investment is being made into the
voluntary sector and
also partner agencies which we may be
able to harness to
make a good value for our older people
as we come out to the
social isolation of colgate 19 so i
think that's something that we can bring
into the delivery the strategy
for for the benefit benefit of our
residents
thank you and i think that is important
i i agree the
term with council dale's comments that
this is an improvement on the strategy
that we first saw
i think the officers time and effort in
producing
this much enhanced document is
appreciated
and with documents like this that to
impact on
local residents across northeast
derbyshire we have to
factor in post code 19
situation and so the the idea that this
should be a
flexible document that isn't set in
stone
is also a welcome so i agree with all of
those comments
and i think council dale your addition
of 6.2 for recommendations that
we review progress of the strategy in
may 2021
and is that formally proposed
yes very happy to propose that thank you
and i'm sure that was seconded uh a
second ago
by casa kenyon so you're happy with that
wording for the
additional recommendation so we're
back to council delton for formal moving
of both recommendations now
yeah happy to move the recommendations
as amended
thank you and second and please oh yes
happy to second
thank you council kenyan all in favor
thank you that is carried so we will
move to the
formal publication of the strategy and
the review
in due course thank you so i
till 5 then visitor
thank you leader and yeah this is the
second draft and this this
has come back as a progress report from
the draft tourism strategy
and i you know i completely agree it's a
much better version
and we have some actual actions in this
one um it is still a work in progress
and we have um obviously a new director
of the economic growth jill who
thinks with us um today and um
you know what you incumbent us to
actually speak to other people like pete
district
regarding the growth strategy and make
sure we're tying in and there's some
statistics and um figures and stuff that
you know we'd like to probe a little bit
more before anything goes out in our
name
um but i know welcome the fact that we
have now got some
actual action points and uh a direction
of travel
we also need to look at the capacity
within the team to actually deliver some
of this
and to put some time scales around it um
and that will include things looking at
our current provision
we are spending some money um with the
two agencies stitching of 18 000 pounds
and i think one of those has been
reviewed and stopped but that will go
back into the
into the pot in terms of actually
supporting some of the actions of this
and whilst we have a moratorium on spend
um as part of the recovery plan which we
um hasn't been finalized yet um
we might have to be begging at some
stage to see if we can do some work
around how we help
local economy in tourism recovery in our
district
um it seems like it possibly will be one
of the last
areas to actually recover and um
we do we also need to look at staff
capacity
within the department there's no reason
why
if there is a spare capacity available
some debt research
particularly during the benchmarks this
in the recommendations at the end
of the tourism strategy draft where we
can actually start to look at
our tours and businesses events and
better ways of publicizing our local
tourism economy
and so hopefully somebody can second
this um and we can then carry on and i
think uh
while living documents seem to be the
phrase of the day i think this is also
going to be a living document which will
be updated um to coincide with the
recovery plan and the wake of covert
thanks or questions from the cabinet
canyon yes it's very welcome to see it
starting to shape
it takes shape now i would definitely
reiterate what counselor renik said
about
resourcing it um there's the one of the
actions
in the plan is to uh recruit a visitor
economy officer
i think that's absolutely key going
forward especially given
the circumstances we find ourselves in
or that our tourism industry finds
itself in rather
thank you did you want to respond yeah
yeah
yeah no yeah we could be aware of that
and i think um
jill's only been in the job at three
four days uh i think she you know we've
obviously got to look at
our current capacity if we can divert
some resource and like i said
we have got two subcontracts out and
that we need to review
to see if that money could be pulled to
maybe put into um
into an officer um i think there's quite
a lot of ground work but
we'll we'll we'll hopefully come back
with an update on that but yeah i'm
mindful well we've got a moratorium at
the moment um
it might be we might be looking for a
bit more resource perhaps to
keep this one into action as and well we
can do it as recovery
thank you from my point of view i've
just got a range of comments and
i would like to formally welcome jill to
the authority
and uh i think this is a really good
start now on the tourism strategy
and from my perspective i think the
partnerships thing is going to be very
crucial
and we've touched on the derbyshire
county council and the joint working
with the county
in terms of vision derbyshire and the
sort of cultural and
ideas that they have got planned for
this year obviously waylaid for a
certain reason
but i also think working with bolzova
district council in terms of strategic
alliance and some possibilities
in trying to attract visitors to
a north derbyshire area so that there's
over spill for balls over attractions
such as crestfall crags and bolts over
castle etcetera
and then coming into northeast
derbyshire for furniture hall
and southern scarsdale and all the other
things that
people might want to come and visit but
i also think we ought to think about
partnerships with some parish councils
i am aware that in some parishes across
northeast derbyshire
there are some ideas for events that
they want to stage
so when i was last in eckington for
example and there were ideas around some
cultural activities
and celebration of the sith wolves
that was muted obviously before kobe
um arrived but this could be something
we could explore for next year
so i think cultural events that are
innovative and new but celebrate things
that have happened here in northeast
derbyshire
some of them historic but some of them
we could create so that we almost
developed
a calendar of events that bring people
to northeast derbyshire
uh with lots of different things
happening from the drone field
beer festival to whatever so there's
something for everyone
and it makes them want to come here so
working with town and paris council is
ought to feature in our plan as well
um councillor dale yeah i'm not sure
whether barry's on the call or not but
if not i'm sure if he were here he would
be saying also it'd be fantastic if we
could tie it up with the
derbyshire uh sort of idea where we're
doing events up and down the country to
mark some of the key um key landmark
dates for example florence nightingale
uh the bison tenerife of birth i believe
uh
various other things that we're doing uh
which i think will be even more so
important
um following the uh the code
pandemic and the needs to get derbyshire
back on its feet
i was at the meeting in dallas county
council to discuss the festival
uh unfortunately by centenary of france
nightingale we're in it now
and so the the planned ideas probably
will have to wait
but i'm sure some of these things we
ought to come back to and revisit
despite the time
being different but there are other
activities that were planned for example
a celebration of edward carpenter the
famous poet
who lived in milthorpe and uh there's
ideas
about that so all of these things
postcoded that need to be
thought about and so at the moment these
things aren't time-bound in our action
planning the strategy
but we need to start putting time-bound
targets into there as well as the
resourcing that we
heard mentioned of as well council
kenyan do tell us about just looking out
just looking out there what a shame that
uh they're having to cancel all their
various events right now because
uh the virus is obviously one of the
strategic things it is in the
plan already i believe
you've all heard far too much about the
uh the canal but
obviously a killer boat lift and opening
the canal through to the rest of the
navigation would be a massive win um
if anybody can shake the government hard
on that but the reason i wanted to
interject was um there was one piece in
there that i'd just say be wary of which
is
uh it's uh page 20 of the strategy
developer visitor economy business
network i'll just say
experience of the business networks that
we've had is
you need to make sure that you really
define what you mean by that otherwise
it's
it's just a talking shop for people
trying to sell their web design service
to
anybody else who's gone along and i
wouldn't like to see the equivalent
happen in the visitor economy
in a visitor economy business network if
one was
created yeah i think that's a very fair
point councillor kenyon
we've seen that happen in other
districts where it's become a talking
shop
i think we have to look
this is currently the functions of
written homes board prior to the new
structure
so this has been in place for a number
of years and we've continued with
uh the same functions until such time as
the new structure
takes over at which point this will be
reviewed in line with the shareholder
agreement so there'll be
a change to this in line with that if
that makes sense
so this i think what we're saying
currently in this paper because of the
hobbit situation and the fact that we
haven't moved to the new structure yet
we are continuing with the existing
board structure but we have made changes
to the directors on the board and we are
looking to recruit two new directors
but we will maintain the same functions
for the time being
yes thank you as well as when we get to
the point of of laying it out
for the uh
just to be absolutely clear i think
there's an awful lot of detailed work to
be done in terms of
social articles etc and shareholder
agreements and
and we have got a project plan in place
and we are working through that and
sarah has done a briefing there which
perhaps wants to come in
but we will be bringing that back in
some more detail too
hopefully an informal cabinet first so
we can have quite a long discussion
about that and how it will work
thank you yeah i i i'm
still a sort of vein and it's a work in
progress
and um for now it's fine but i just
wondered if we got any more progress
around the um interest you know in the
fact we've got problems with the
a number of councils on the board and
interest in voting
and where there are other avenues that
have been explored to make that easier
to operate this just
um yeah i'm i'm not quite sure what the
interest question is
could i ask i think once you ask about
what it would mean if they're members of
the wrigle board
and when it came to actually voting in
the council
forum do they have to an interest in the
same way as they did before
or has something changed and my view is
that it won't have changed but
let's be your answer no you're quite
right it won't have changed
board members are paid they do have
disclosure cuny interests
therefore they shouldn't be in the room
according to our constitution
and shouldn't be speaking and voting on
it
it's a separation of the roles could i
also just add in relation to the project
plan
um we're not quite at the stage where
we've got a project plan
we are producing we already have had one
draft and we're going on to the next one
um with all the strands of work that
needs doing for this to be in place for
the first of october
so we're working actively on that we're
on to our second draft
and yes we would aim to come to an
informal cabinet
exact draft when it's ready thank you
council renee yeah no just
but when you and just just to a question
to sarah
um when you talk about the the our rules
you say that then
our rules could change to help um
with this issue in terms of having to
lose so many counselors out of the
chamber on
important votes or is this a legal
issue that would prevent us from doing
that
it's law it's not something we've chosen
to adopt it is the law
they have a disclosure because interest
making people available the chamber is
clearer the kevin
had previously considered this and
that's why the number of people on the
sub boards
is duplicated otherwise you'd have half
the council leaving the room
and no one left to vote potentially or
it would make him
some committees difficult to manage with
the some of the members having to leave
so
hence the duplication of one or two
members of sub boards and the holding
board
we did consider it so that the numbers
still
mean that voting can take place and
those members
declaring interest would leave and
wouldn't uh strike again
a terribly out of uh balanced
yeah i'm just i suppose can't believe
that
we're in a situation where we are sort
of hindered by this
um i just wanted to make sure we
absolutely have explored all the
possibilities and all the ways of
actually
uh ways of getting around that in other
forms
whether it's different ways of
constituting the
the the boards themselves but i am it
does seem a bit
normally that that we can't potentially
get our own business through
our own council it's not an anomaly this
is this is how local government works
you know we we don't try to get around
something these are the
the legal reasons why um we have to
think about this
that is the situation that's a legal
requirement
whether it's this board or any other
board that we are members of
if there's a conflict of interest we
have to declare it and we leave
that that is that and the cabinet has
actually
thought this through um so that it
doesn't impact on business original
and neither does it impact on decision
making of the council
mr stern yeah i just wanted to add to
that to say you are dealing with two
different legal entities you have the
council as one
and you have the company as the other
they are separate legal entities
and therefore it's not just a case of
getting council business through a
committee
it is a separate body with its own rules
and its own responsibilities and its own
duties
thank you any other comments or
questions
if not are you return to council pal
then for recommendations please
well can i uh can i move the
recommendations at the
gender item six um are noted
and acted upon did you have a second uh
yeah thank you council relic all in
favor
thank you that is carried so we'll
that's the counter cupid to return
and council dale so
now i'm just
i'm back
just waiting for the castle qp so
an opportunity to mute himself
thank you
i'll try not to have a sneezing vid
today thank you
thank you that would that be a computer
virus
uh it's best i could do well it looks
like council cupid
is back so we'll move to item 7 which is
the clay crosstown deal update
item some of the papers there
um this is again another
date on what's happening with the clay
crosstown centre board
and you'll see it set out in the papers
uh where we're at we did have a
cross board meeting recently via virtual
means to talk about procurement
and exercise for consultants and that
is scheduled now for this friday
there's been a um a sifting exercise
we've had a significant number who've
expressed interest
in the next stage of uh supporting the
board in terms of consultancy
and so this friday the there are five
people who are going to be involved in
interviews with those consultants and
then
a town center board will be convened on
friday afternoon
to confirm the one that is the
recommended
consultant to work as we move into the
next
stage so 1.12 outlines of people who've
been
designated as members of the board who
will actually be
at looking consultancy aspects but the
whole board will be convened
to um to actually ratify the decision
i think that's really where we're at the
paper is self-explanatory
um are there any comments or questions
from any of the cabinet
thank you i'll move to the
recommendations
so it's set out at 6.1 and do we have a
second to please
thank you council parking all in favor
thank you that's carried so item eight
accessable disability access
guys that's myself again and as you know
we were concerned to try and press this
forward with then working with access
able
a company that specializes in producing
an app
for people with disabilities to consider
areas that they were visiting
preparing for those areas that were
accessible to them so it could be pubs
restaurants that sort of thing
maybe leisure centers all the
information that they need to plan
their visit we have met
with the people from accessable and a
range of uh
offer details were outlined and
costs we decided that the best way
forward was to talk to parish and town
councils
about sharing some of those costs so
that
we could look at what they could provide
for their own parish areas in terms of
access
accessible places so that was put to a
parish
town board meeting
and information was sent to all partisan
town councils
with the costings for each of their own
areas
however in the meantime code with 19
appeared so where no more work has been
done
on this at all so it has actually been
paused
so if i mean frank i'm disappointed in
that
it's been very slow to progress
and unfortunately we've not been able to
get to the stage where somebody was
going to come out and start the
work in terms of assessments going
around the areas
looking at buildings and working out all
of the
accessibility issues
i think that's about as much as i want
to say in terms of where we're at are
there any comments or questions
about the report
council renee and then council kenyan
yeah just wondering if you had somebody
in mind to do the assessments because i
would have thought somebody assessing a
building in isolation
was perfectly uh feasible and allowable
at this
in this juncture and uh i can i'm doing
exactly that with uh one of the parish
premises at the moment while the
preschool aren't there we've got plenty
of time to look at these things
company access able has their own
people doing the risk assessments and
they are specialists
in issues to do with people with
disabilities in fact some of the people
are carrying out the work have
disabilities themselves so they are
aware of
issues around wheelchair access that
type of thing so there are specialists
in it
so the purchase of this app and all that
comes with it the support mechanisms etc
also includes someone from the company
coming to do the risk assessments
council canyon uh yes uh do we know if
they're
actually able to do the assessments
right now would be one question
then also i'm just thinking is it
possible to turn it around a little bit
and i don't know if we've got a database
that can do this or not
if we had a way to generate a list of
all the
candidate businesses and organizations
and so each parish was given a list of
their
30-40 things so
spark the the process maybe
that's a good question i think in the um
information we sent out to parishes
we told them what the cost was
depending on the parish size and the
number of buildings that they wanted to
have included
in this app so it's down to the parish
and town council to decide
how they want to manage the buildings
that they choose to put in
so for example in my own parish we would
have gone to the the shop
and the pubs in the in in the
area said would you like to be included
because they in turn might want to say
yes and they make a financial
contribution
or the parish themselves say well we'll
pay for it
and the costs will be covered by all us
but we can only afford
x number of businesses and we will
decide who they are
so it's it is the paris and town
councils who will make that decision
to happen in terms of
can we do
with all the social distancing rules and
so on i think that's a question for a
disabled and
my own view is that we
exist now because the the whole idea of
this was to fit in with visitor economy
work
and while the weather was going to be
nice tears and
and people people going out into the
northeast side and all the things that
come with nice weather it could be to
make best use of the
beam which isn't cheap let's be honest
and we want to get value for money it
could be that
again so that we can
alert ready for the the new visitor
season so to speak
making best use of the now paying for a
year that we we might have to write off
because of coronavirus
any other comments or questions
if not then i moved first of all noting
the content of the report
but uh in terms of 6.2 approved
the um re-commencing of this initiative
i think that re-commencing should be
spring
2021 that's my view
unless anybody has a controversy
if not then then do we have a second
here for the recommendations please
thank you council kenyan all in favor
thank you that's kerry thank you so
there are no
urgent items so we move to item 10
i move that the public be excluded from
the meeting during the discussion of the
following items of business
to avoid the disclosure to them of
exempt information as defined in part
one of schedule 12
8 local government 1972
as amended by the local government
access to information variation order
2006.
so it's those items from 11 onwards
where the public
are excluded do you have a second for
that
thank you council lapel all in favor
thank you so the public are excluded so
uh governance can you confirm that there
were no public members online